hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game played in 1863 in
Manchester between Alexander Stein Cola
and Joseph Henry Blackburn who they
called the Black Death now we've covered
a few games by Joseph Henry Blackburn by
now and those of you who have been
following the channel for quite some
time know why they call him the black
death or at least why we think they call
him the Black Death
but for those of you who are perhaps new
to the channel why do you think they
called him the Black Death and also we
are using the photo of the hoodie guy
since we know nothing about mr. Stein
Cola other than the fact that he played
a match against Joseph in Blackburn in
1863 in Manchester and that he drew a
game against Wilhelm Stein it's 11 years
after this game in 1874 also in
Manchester so he was he was definitely a
capable player but this game it's a
blindfold game now I don't know if both
of them are actually playing blindfolded
or just mr. Blackburn here but either
way it's a very enjoyable game so
without further ado let's check it out
and also do be a part of the subscribers
video it's gonna be awesome
if you don't know what it is all the
needed information will be in the
description below so do check it out so
with the white pieces alexander cencula
opens with E 4 we have E 5 Knight 2 3
Knight to c6 and now Bishop to c4 detail
in game we have Bishop to c5 and now c3
the main line of the Joko piano
we have Knight to f6 and now d4 by white
so white gnosis theory we have ECAP
recently for C characters and Bishop to
b4 check by blackburn now for some
reason why didn't go for Knight to c3
the greco attack white counter with
Bishop to d2 which is also playable is
just especially in those days Knight to
c3 was considered the main line for
those of you who don't know what the
greco attack is the greco attack is the
greatest attack in chess it follows
after Knight to c3 black grabs a pawn
and white just castles and here well
there are a lot of ways to play this but
in the old days
well weaker players would often capture
on c3 and after pawn captures the bishop
captures on c3 attack the rook white
would go Queen to b3 put pressure on f7
and also attack the bishop here so here
you have to play b5 if you want to
survive anything but a weaker players
use to capture on a1 and then you just
get better of captures on f7 check King
f8 and Bishop to g5 the queen has
nowhere to go you have to block with the
night and after 97 rook you want and
that's just it next move you're gonna
capture on e7 and it's game over so
that's what the Greco attack is and how
it was played in the old old days but
there's also III don't know if you
remember is I made this video like three
years ago it's called the boy who wanted
to play chess or something like that
when tarush or maybe children I think it
was children and sugar children held a
simultaneous exhibition and then he
played against a little kid and reached
this position with white and then after
Bishop to g5 the kid didn't block with
97 the kid just played a Knight captures
on d4 but chigorin was also playing some
blindfolded and he didn't know what to
play here he thought the kid you know
beat the the greco attack which was you
know the greco attack he has stood the
test of time and here children was very
impressed and he didn't find Queen e3
check you just check the pink and next
movie pick up the Queen he continued the
game in some other fashion I don't know
maybe he just captured the Queen and and
continued the game Indian he won the
game I would he was very very sad that
that the kid didn't really you know beat
the greco attack if you're interested in
that video and if you also want to have
a good laugh because it's a really old
video and well do check it out I will
also put a link to it in the description
below it will be the first thing you
will see but okay now that's a for that
video after Bishop to b4 check no greco
attack Bishop to d2 by mr. Stein kula
we have Bishop captures and now not
Knight B character sandy - which would
be reasonable as both of these phones
are now defended but instead why it was
for Knight FCAT for Sandy - so makes no
sense that that's why I don't know if
both of them were playing blindfold or
what
or or is just some sort of a tricky pawn
sacrifice well whatever it is the Black
Death accepts the pawn on d4 with knife
cut for Sunday for white castles and now
d6 we have Knight to b3 now offering
your trade of knights Knight captures on
b3 Queen captures on b3 now putting
pressure on f7 and here black just
castles we have rook to e1 defending the
pawn here and the now Knight to the h5
Blackburn makes room for the Queen to
come on h4 and then you want to play or
g5 and then you want to play Knight to
f4 create threats against the g2 pawn
well that's basically the plan and here
again white should continue Knight to c3
each you just continue developing pieces
but instead he goes he 5 and ok probably
to open up some lines then go Knight c3
get rook to d1 maybe with an attack on
the Queen either way okay
Blackburn goes Queen to g5 now preparing
Knight to f4 we have a captures on d6
what just grabs upon with Knight to f4
threatening made here and here white
place and Bishop captures on f7 usual
place I'm like Queen g3 and then trade
Queens and then and then continue
playing the game white is that white is
even better here but he went for Bishop
captures on f7 check and here in black
grunts own words he says this tempting
but unsound move led to all his
subsequent troubles so here of course if
you capture the bishop then rook e8 is
mating one since the rook is now pinned
however blackburn just moved the king we
have king 288 and now you still have to
defend against mate so g3 and here
blackburn doesn't continue with
knowledge to recheck first he decides to
grab this pawn it is someone it is a
blindfold game after all we have Knights
the c3 now finally continuing
development and only now Knight to h3
with check with King to g2 and the now
Queen to f6
pressuring the bishop and also the F do
pawn so what do you play here here white
it's a very interesting position and I'm
just gonna show it I don't know if I if
if there's a point in showing a since
its applied blindfold game you know
played in 1863 but it's a very enjoy
position so I will show it here white
played Bishop to d5 he was a very greedy
he wanted to control everything but f3
actually allows white to continue
playing the game for example if rook
captures on f7 you have rook to e8 with
check rook the f8 and now Knight to e4
you attack the Queen and the Queen
doesn't really have any good squares if
Queen f5 you just push the Queen back
and the problem is black has rook
captures any age now you can give up the
Queen and now rook the e2 with check
King f1 and now Bishop to e6 attack the
Queen Queen captures on b7 and now
Bishop to c4 and now the game continues
since white is unable to grab the rook
white would have to figure out something
else like Queen to c6 or something point
is that if you capture the rib then rook
blocks with a discover to check from the
bishop and then now after King g2 now
you just pick up the Queen and well both
of the nicer hanging surges gonna move
this Knight let's say Knights to e4 and
then you just get Bishop to e6 defending
the knight and the game continues and
well black is basically black is up a
piece so white will not be able to
capture on e8 but there was a way to
continue the game with f3 however White
was either greedy or you know he missed
it it was a blindfold game he played
Bishop to d5 but now black has a forced
checkmate in a forced checkmate in four
moves and it's what Blackburn calls the
clean mate not sure if black bird I
don't think Blackburn coined the term
clean mate I just I mean I I follow a
lot of chess and I've never heard of the
term clean mate so I feel free to pause
the video and try to find it this clean
mate in four moves while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations on
finding such a clean mate even though
III don't really know what a clean mate
is and for those who just want to enjoy
the show its Queen captures on f2 with
check I'm sure we all found that one
Quinta h1 and now Queen to g1 check you
sacrifice the Queen rook captures on g1
now comes Knights the f2 with check so
if this was made it will be a smothered
mate but since you still have King to g2
now Bishop delivers mate with Bishop to
h3 and this is what Blackburn calls a
clean mate and we also have the quote
above the board in chest language this
is a clean mate and is considered one of
the most beautiful ever produced in
actual play now I don't know if he's
referring to this game exactly is this
the most beautiful mate ever produced in
actual play or just that clean mates are
the most beautiful mates produced in
actual play but whatever it is a
beautiful mate so all like a smothered
mate although King still has one more
move after it's not a smart mate and
then the bishop delivers made I guess
for a clean mate so yeah maybe maybe
that's what it would clean mate is
whatever it is it is beautiful and I I
didn't Utley did enjoy it and I hope you
enjoyed it as well and I would like to
thank many men I've ekam for suggesting
this game using hashtag suggestion so
thank you for that and it was really
nice to take a small break from modern
chess so I would also like to thank
Joseph McGinnis and Christos gnosis for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos here I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon are continuing well starting
basically the coverage of the Fida Grand
Prix the last leg continue to check up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one and whatever else happens in
the chess world and once again do be a
part of the subscribers video if you
don't know what it is
check the description below so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day